hey everybody and welcome to the live
coding with Jessie and today we're gonna
do something that I've never done on
livestream so we're actually going to do
some design work so we may do some some
coding of things depending on how
quickly we figure out this design but I
was looking basically at you know a
blank that blank area between the hero
section and the footer that we have and
thinking all right what are we gonna do
here and I have some idea but I thought
it might be good to you know kind of
plan it out a little bit you know better
than then I had been I think it'll save
us time in the end because there's a lot
of content so if I just start going in
and coding I think we may end up having
to change the code back and forth a lot
so normally I'm ok with that
and I actually preferred to just throw
some code in there and see what what
happens on the page but in this case
there's just there's a lot of that was
looking through the content there's
there's so much content so at least the
first part of the stream we're going to
go through these are just some
screenshots of the top of the site and
we're gonna go through some of the
things and figure out what we can cut
out completely and where we want the
rest of this information to go how we
want to format it yeah so that's the
plan I'm using sketch to do this so I
know I I usually get someone who asks
what what tool I'm using so this is just
sketch and just took screenshots copied
and pasted them into here and I'm just
using the simple
a pencil tool here and I'll just mark
things up you know right on the screen
normally I would sketch something on a
notebook but you won't be able to see
that so that's what I'm gonna try to do
it here on the screen and let's let me
check the lab chat before we get started
hey everybody who's there
harsh deep uh asking me to reply how's
it going let's see okay everything looks
good let's check and make sure I had my
mic on because everybody would have
saying hello there's people sent a lot
with question marks and things so it is
on it's registering that I'm talking so
I think it think it's working all right
so let's get started
so just so we all are on the same page
in case you haven't been watching we
have this is our new version of the home
page so I am a front-end developer for
university working on a new homepage for
the university so this is what we have
so far
this is just a placeholder image will
get different image there's still some
placeholder text here but we're probably
going to end up having something here
you know call to action some text and we
just put this footer in a few days ago
so now we need something to go here and
this is the site it's Franciscan CDU so
you know you could check out the site
the live site if you want but I'm gonna
be working with this you know this
version here like I said it's just a
screenshot so here's what
you need to keep so we definitely need
to keep I might need to change the the
width let's change the thickness of this
cuz that's too too fine that's good with
the two of five looks like there yeah
that's a little bit better alright so we
have to keep this in some form we can
want the thickness to stay it so I
actually don't you sketch that much so
that's why I'm I'm not sure how to set
the thickness and make it stay like that
so anyway
so we can get rid of this we can I'm not
sure about this I kind of I want to keep
this in some form but I'm not sure what
the best way to keep this is I have some
ideas about this and I'll show you in a
minute
the events and news we need to keep
these somehow this section could
probably be some sort of banner like
like that we deal with project one like
some sort of quote quote banner like a
full-width bar across the screen that's
a solid color we could do this maybe you
know just put the quote in here yeah
that might work
the videos
I'm not sure about the videos we could
potentially make them more prominent you
know have them be larger and side by
side you know make a whole section of it
I want to I want to be careful that the
site doesn't end up being longer than it
already is now what we can get rid of
that'll help with that is pencil I
should use the shortcut well we can get
rid of is this isn't that working out so
good all right so we're gonna get rid of
all these banner images so I've just
brought in one but I mean that's every
one of these sections is pretty much the
same so the banner images will be gone
these links on the side so I cut it off
but there's a bunch of links here
they're almost exactly the same links
that we have in the side nav so I think
we can get rid of these links we don't
have to worry about that this middle
section has content we'll keep that text
content and then this sidebar has you
can see so we have it here as well
this information is almost
I don't want to say we can completely
get rid of it but I think it's secondary
secondary information so we may want to
do something like I don't know take take
this and in something like this down
here and put it together in its own
section you know across so we can't get
really get rid of a lot I mean we could
sure I could try talking to my boss to
see if we could get rid of even more but
for now we have to deal with these
sections this section for right now I'm
gonna say let's get rid of this we may
have to keep it while doing some weird
stuff we may have to keep this section
but for now I'm not gonna worry about it
we'll work it in somehow later on if I
if I have to keep it in so the first
thing I think we should do is figure out
what we're gonna do for these you know
what kind of design we're gonna use they
need this section needs to still be near
the top of the page in the same way I
think with the news and events I know my
boss does not want the news and events
tabbed he wants them you know both to be
visible so here's what I'm thinking so
we'll have our main hero section like we
normally have and then the next section
will be three probably three cards in
those cards my first thought is this and
I think maybe we ought to try it out and
see how it looks because I'm not sure
about it I've never done this exactly
like I'm gonna well I'll tell you the
idea and let let you off
let me know what you think some idea is
this I'm gonna take news events and then
that top section that has some student
profiles really the other two is to go
back to this these other two here or
really could fall under news and events
right so same ones yeah these are both
really events so I don't think we need
an extra section for this so basically
it'll be student highlights news events
we're all gonna combine into one but
since we'll have multiple ones I'm
thinking that each one of these cards
could basically be like a carousel that
you could flip through I've never done a
carousel with an entire card as the the
carousel so I'd like to try it out it's
not that hard to do a carousel in with
materialised so I think we can get it
working in a few minutes and at least
get something on the page to see if it
works on a small screen of course these
would stack and they be swipeable you
know with a touch gesture I think it's
worth a shot
the only thing that some details that
I'm not sure about is what do we do
about you know images we're gonna have
images with text they want more like a
traditional card like image up here text
below do we want to try to an overlay I
kind of think especially for the news
that's going to be way too much text for
just an overlay you know we also have
other options like something that
reveals right so you have the title here
and it can slide up and reveal so I
think we have a lot of leeway to try
different things but let's just get
something basic
on the page for now so we'll probably
end up going back and forth between
sketch and between our code editor and
just kind of putting the pieces on there
and I don't want to spend too much time
in sketch really because this drawing
things not working out like I hoped it's
hard to see and it's it's really hard to
actually draw with with this touchpad
I'd hope that be able to write notes and
everything but it's just gonna look ugly
all right so let's give this a shot so
here we have let's see I don't want that
let's see templates our homepage meet
our homepage wireframe our testing page
wireframe ok so we definitely need to
make sure that we grab this data but for
now we may not be able to use this data
as is right because let me bring the the
actual site over let's see I had it up
here we go ok so
sorry here we go
just lost my train of thought okay now I
remember so in the actual site you can
see like the images are very different
so if I put in the data right now as is
I'm gonna get different size images and
I'm gonna get this text content
formatted differently in you know
different tags so it's it's not even
consistent you know throughout so even
on here like these are not this is just
regular text inside divs these are in h2
tags so there's not even really any
consistency between these right now so
we'll just use some some test data we'll
hard-code some in there just to see what
it looks looks like then what we'll have
to do is go in and figure out where that
data is coming from like is there
another like sub template that is coming
from or is a lot of this you know all in
a WYSIWYG editor I'm not sure but we
need to make sure that everything comes
through in a more uniform way for the
calendar I'm a little bit worried
because we don't actually have images
right unless we want to you know up here
we have some images so we may need to
start having images added in or to think
about you know an entirely different set
up I'm just I'm not sure I know that
behind the scenes to manage the calendar
content it's kind of a mess right now
you can't just add in an event and tag
it and have it show up in different
places so there are several different
calendars and you'd have to manually
copy and paste event details into like
four different places for it to get
everywhere it needs to on the site so
that's not ideal it might not be a bad
idea to just come up with some different
system I'm kind of even thinking you
know pull that data in from somewhere
else set up some
their system so I don't know as long as
its system as an API we could pull the
data from it doesn't really matter what
it is but anyway you know that's
probably a question for later on right
now we'll just get something on here and
see what it looks like I'm gonna check
the latch act quickly because I'm
interested to see if anyone has any
thoughts on this so far
hmm
John did make a comment here about the
the idea to reveal text over images
onmouseover so my thought was not to do
mouse over if I was going to do it
I had thought maybe to have just the
title showing and then a little icon to
indicate that you could click it and
make the the rest of it slide up as an
overlay or I mean I can show you some of
the some of the options here that are
already built in and materialized that
we could work with or edit it if we
needed to
so I mean here's our basic we could do
image title content and then obviously
our link I mean that'll definitely work
or we could do something like this where
we have a reveal that slides up right so
it's it's on click I I don't know I
think that's that's a possibility as
well it kind of depends on how much
content I don't want these cards to be
huge but I'd rather avoid making users
click if they don't have to so although
there's a benefit if we do something
like this then more content could be
right there on the home page users won't
have to go to another page you know to
get a lot of content so we'll see but
those kind of decisions aren't gonna lie
completely with with me that's gonna be
something that you know other people
here in my department will probably
weigh in on but at first let's just grab
if at first this simple card will get
the cards laid out and then maybe we'll
wrap it in a carousel and see see what
we can do
so I'm just gonna grab this since we're
already importing everything from
materialized the CSS the JavaScript this
all should just work right off the bat
if you remember a few days ago I
completely removed all the other styles
that were in this site so we shouldn't
have any conflicts obviously the image
is not going to work so we are going to
need to replace that you know with some
other image and actually we could
probably grab the image URL from one of
the images that are being used right now
on on the site and just put that in that
might not be a bad idea because it'll be
you know more realistic for the type of
image that we're actually going to use
okay
yeah
okay here's our hero section
I think that may remove all of this
stuff right now and just start from
scratch and then when we need to pull in
some data you know we need to bring in
something like this then we can just
look at the live version and pull it in
from there hmm
sorry yawning I got it really earlier
with with my youngest today she's almost
1 so a little bit tired it was fun
though she was really cute and wanted to
play all right so I think I think I can
go from here and grab a bunch of this a
fun I think it'll be much faster if we
just start from scratch then trying to
look through this I think it's just
gonna be distracting okay actually we
could have I think so touchy at the top
here there we go okay so we probably
want to keep this panel I imagine we're
gonna get some errors turn if we take it
out completely all right
we'll probably get some errors thrown no
matter what but we'll see we'll just
need to remove some things from the
c-sharp file and it should be okay
alright so this already has a row I'll
call them nice
so let's paste that in and drop us down
to two spaces there we go
okay and I want to make let's make these
columns exactly how we want so with
materializes column class based on
twelve if we want three columns across
it has to be like twelve divided by
three and so that's how we'll get our
three columns so we can just well that
was crazy
and I apologize if you all can hear my
stomach rumbling over here so I haven't
eaten I said I'm not sure what I ate I
had a blueberry muffin at like 7:00 a.m.
so and I had a few almonds earlier so
I'm really hungry hopefully you all can
hear that but if you can I'm sorry see
all right now we need to throw in an
image so let's get let's see let's see
if we can find this image copy image
address okay and for now we'll just use
this image
and let's see what's going on
yep okay
all right a lot of stuff is probably
gonna give us airs so the way this
homepage is is built out you can
actually so like you can edit it
oops I want to go on I wanted to show
how you can edit it right there in the
page but you can somehow edit things
right in the page switch to edit there
we go
so a lot of these sections let you do
that like this so we have content blocks
I I don't know that I that I care that
much to leave these editable and I know
I've said this before but the thing that
I really want to redo this site
completely from the ground up like not
have it hosted on campus I want to use
you know I basically set it up like
we've been used setting up our other
sites right so I want to have you know
have cloud hosting so several you know
either droplets or you know we may not
go digital ocean but let's say we did we
have you know a bunch of droplets all
running this it would be built with
react and so I'm not that worried about
leaving this as you know editable in
this way it's not gonna get edited
frequently at least until you know let's
say within the next year or so
so some sections will in those sections
then I'll worry about making sure that
it can be edited by people who don't
have access to all the files which
basically it's only me right now and I
think maybe two people in the IT
department so
I think it would just be a lot of work
to try to make all these editable
content blocks I don't I don't think
it's really necessary right now so we
are gonna hard code a lot of this stuff
and then see see how it goes because we
may be able to remove more stuff from
the page anyway and then it would be
kind of a waste to spend all the time
trying to make these you know content
blogs alright so let's get rid of these
errors and I just remembered that I did
not set my timer so let me check what
time it is actually I've definitely been
coding for 25 minutes let's take our
five minutes to go through the live chat
I'm actually really interested in what
everybody's been saying while I've been
going through this so I'm gonna do five
minutes and I'm gonna answer questions
then we're going to do another 25-minute
session for sure we're gonna get some
stuff on the page see how it looks and
then figure out what our next steps
going to be all right
okay Matt Grande asks if I'm working on
a Mac yes I am Amit asked did you learn
from free code Kim yes I learned from a
lot of different places
free code camp was one of them I
actually have not made it all the way
through free code camp so I hope to one
day I've just I bounced around to a lot
of different things and I frequently
just get busy with work and side
projects and don't I haven't had a
chance to finish it yet but I think free
code camp is definitely an amazing
resource to start out learning web
development
okay Matt granddad asked on what servers
is this site hosted so it's actually
hosted on Windows Windows server here on
campus in Steubenville Ohio so the IT
department runs all the servers and it
is dotnet framework so currently that's
that's what we're doing Magnus says how
do you break up the design of a web page
are you following MVC so it's Model View
controller um right now we're not really
following anything because this is
legacy code and we have to work with
what was already there a lot so I don't
have much of a strategy in terms of
organization right now because there's
so much there I don't know that I that I
could without massive effort reorganize
things into something like MVC so right
now I'm just kind of checking out what's
there and trying to work with it not
really how I would do it if I had a
chance to start this project from the
beginning John Hanson says for the for
the UI
he said secondary things could be
contained in some sort of some kind of
accordion drop-down and when opened
don't affect page content flow
yet think I have used accordions before
that's not a bad idea we can try that
out as well let's get some of the cards
up and we'll try out both I do want to
see what it looks like with the carousel
but the accordion could be it could work
I think potentially see a mix working as
well but accordion and carousel the
accordion might work better for the
events all right we'll see what it looks
like i al a I'm not sure you pronounce
that it's al e says what app are you
using to draw the design it's called
sketch it's a as far as I know it's Mac
only and it's like it's a nice
alternative to using Adobe products it's
cheaper I think it's easier to learn at
least for me it was easier to learn
okay ma Mahmoud says can't the news look
like a slideshow if photos in that frame
but then you need to match the other
frames near it yeah I definitely want to
make sure that they match if we're gonna
go all with the same design but I'm
thinking we might be able to get away
with doing something different for the
middle one I think that would still look
kind of balanced let's say we had cards
on the two ends the end columns and then
the middle column would have an
accordion then we might be able to get
away with let's say not even having
images at all for one of those
okay all right almost one are almost the
end of the comments I think there's just
one or two more so I'm just going to
finish reading those and then I'll start
the timer again so Emily says yes
anything to remove those things from
that beautiful building picture plus
idea sounds good alright cool yeah we we
happen to have really good photographers
in our department so we end up getting
some some great pictures sometimes and
even I mean these ones on the main site
I I don't think there are best pictures
but it's really cool to have so much
content in terms of images to choose
from when I do the sites John says are
you gonna remove the max width from the
outer wrapper yeah definitely the max
width is going to be done well I mean
it's I think it's already done we can't
see it right now exit to error but we
definitely don't have a max width on
this version of it so that is not going
to be there
let's see
all right I'm gonna go back I'll come
back so if if you have a question in
there I didn't get to it I'll get to it
after this next session okay so let's
fix these errors so we have line 21
check it out line 21 oh yeah all this
stuff has to go
interesting
oh alright I remember looking at this
before there's some weird stuff going on
give me a second
interesting
um I'm very interested so line 21 should
have never even attempted actually maybe
I'm thinking about this wrong so a
c-sharp is compiled right is this I used
to
I'm obviously used to JavaScript and in
JavaScript if I had an if statement the
things inside the if statement wouldn't
even get evaluated unless that was true
so I could have errors inside my if
statement and it wouldn't it wouldn't
happen so what I'm having now is this if
statement that should should never have
run because these conditions aren't true
but I'm still getting an error in here
so I guess that means the C sharp is
actually checking all these
possibilities which I mean that kind of
stinks no I I don't need I guess I'll
take all these up we have panel top we
don't have these so let's get rid of
this for now actually I'm gonna take it
out completely you know we have we have
a backup
and I am tracking all this in a private
get repo so if I really mess it up I
could always just revert back all right
let's see what else we have
oh-ho I expected more errors but all
right not bad let's see it's to pull
this out of it yes you can see right now
it's definitely full with I probably
want to have more margin than this
so we'll fix that in a second but I
don't know how big this image is
originally but that doesn't look that
bad and these are these are quite big so
I imagine this image is probably larger
than it needed needs to be okay all
right let's
let's give this marches on the side and
we can do that by adding a container and
I let me let me do this this let's see
so I'm gonna do dot container yes all
right I'm trying to learn how to do this
this shortcut stuff with with Emmett
dang it I copy and paste it like that
because I thought that it would
automatically indent it properly but it
didn't anyway this should give us what
we want and let me I'm gonna move this
over here so I don't have to keep
swiping past it let's see what this
gives us whoa much smaller I don't
really know that I want that much I mean
this is quite a large screen so maybe
when we get down lower there's less of a
margin I may end up adjusting that
margin that's a lot what is that
settling right now
oh wow so the width is 70% hmm yeah I
mean that's that's small deeds oh oh oh
adjust that later on I mean one good
thing about setting that with like that
is otherwise you have this huge range
you have to cover with these images they
get I mean they just get really big you
could always set a max width on the
cards themselves so I mean we have some
options there all right so the next step
is let's make at least one of these two
carousel and we'll make one of these in
accordion and we'll have to add in some
extra data just to see you know how it
would look you know if there was real
data in there okay
let's get the let's get the code from
materialize so here so let's go down
here let's grab this
I don't want to carousel fool with
all right let's let's initialize this
carousel first we need to find our
JavaScript
okay so within our document dot ready
function which this is shorthand for so
we're using jQuery we're gonna put in
this and this is just going to
initialize our carousel and now I'm
gonna bring in some of those cares
let me see I may not need though all
that I'm just trying to see what the
difference is
okay I am gonna need some of this so I
needed to make the cards carousel items
so let's make this first card I carousel
item and I'll just copy this in here and
then we'll grab this card we'll grab
that card and we're gonna put it in here
in place of each of these these panels
actually what we need to do I think we
should put the class carousel fixed item
on the card itself so let's do that
she goes that class cares so fixed item
there we go and I will paste this you
know maybe just two more times I'm not
gonna worry about this indentation just
killing me all right let's see if that's
enough to make this work
whoa no it's not what do we miss
let's see I'm missing something
do we need that HF
you might need the HF
hmm
so let me switch up and use these cares
so I don't
oh I know what I did I made them all
carousel fixed items and that's not what
I should have done
alright let's say that so in in the
example the fixed item is this button so
you can see the button stays there even
though the background changes so that's
not what you want let's see if that made
a difference Wow still didn't make a
difference hmm okay
it just keeps getting worse I'm gonna
take one more look at the demo stuff
actually I should take a look at at the
console see if we're getting some sort
of error are we getting
where are we talking about fancy bugs oh
there I thought we got rid of that
did we get rid of that
that's really weird
mine
I'm not preserving the log all right so
you all see this I'm getting an error
for something that I had already removed
unless this isn't a different part maybe
have it twice now this may not be
related to why the this other stuffs not
working or though yeah because I mean we
have this working so that's probably not
a problem here but maybe it's maybe they
have that in the and the header
somewhere
now it is here
all right then
let's get rid of that
and obviously couldn't find it because
we weren't using that okay so not
probably not our problem for down here
but still good to get rid of that that
error okay that's going all right now
let's see what's going on with these
okay so we've got to care so I don't
well I think something has is probably
getting overridden in here because it
looks like I mean you can see the
JavaScript is taking effect or these are
all added dynamically right so we have a
display so this is supposed to display
and which should happen
okay
oops
haha okay this is what I did
I am I copied this whole thing so I've
actually made three different carousels
so I'm sure one of you already pointed
that out to me sorry I didn't check the
live chat sooner but that's why that's
why I were just playing it three times
because I told it to display it three
times okay whoops that last div no I
think we're fine let's double check
though okay so I need to remove this div
and then add in a div down here okay all
right now let's see I really need to get
some sort of Auto formatting plug-in
okay so that's not exactly what I wanted
to happen but I removed a bunch of stuff
just to test it so that's how it's
coming up this is the default carousel I
actually kind of like this but not for a
card obviously there's not enough space
for that it would have to be I couldn't
fit three in a row here but we can see
carousels working so let's just add in
our let's see what was that class name
okay so slider and we may also have to
add in full with true let's try this
first yeah we need full with true let's
go here and let's make sure
okay
let's see if this does the trick kind of
almost let's see what's going on here
I wonder if it would make more sense
then mmm I was thinking about making the
column leave the care so yeah but that's
that's not gonna work that would then
make this full width alright so this
might not be so easy with materialised
not to say we couldn't make it work the
way we want it but at least for right
now it's not it's not working out
exactly as we want yeah let's let's
check this let's see what we're getting
the width from oh okay it's it's
actually set to 200 pixels all right I
don't want that we can get okay
that's better
okay not perfect but you can see
basically this is this would be more of
the behavior that we would get it's kind
of a little weird flash there I don't
like that was
hmm
for some reason this is getting cut off
why is it
it's an interesting
okay the Charis Charis the carousel
itself is too short that's the problem
oK we've made it a bit bigger there we
go let's take that light off it - yeah
whoa so I guess it needs some kind of
fight this this may be more modification
than it's really worth maybe we should
think up a different different way to do
this yeah it's not like we can really
give it a fixed height because this
should change based on the width
I don't know let's let me take the last
chat quickly cuz I see a lot of stuff in
here
okay
I guess like I mean I could for now
manually give it some a better height
let's see you got an idea said why not
just set max Heights we can see if
that'll bring it back no I mean it's
possible that if I refreshed it
yeah actually when I got a knock at the
door a thing gets my kids so they might
be on the show hey you wanna be on
YouTube look at this camera right there
you see the little green light that's
what they can see you say hi
look at the green light and say hi this
green
[Music]
it's that was my three-year-old Ambrose
and my wife brought me some food so that
was awesome Ambrose is a cute little man
he's very ordinary now so they say they
talk about terrible twos he was fine as
a two-year-old but three is just like
he's been crazy since he turned 3 so but
he's so cute like it's hard to stay mad
at him yesterday I got a text from my
wife and it was a picture of him in the
bathtub with all his clothes on so I get
it and a bunch of toys like non bath
toys so I guess he had just grabbed a
bunch of stuff and got in so he does
stuff like that and it's cute and he
also took all the shampoo and dumped it
out in the bathtub and it was pretty
much full so but I mean that's a the
little kids are so they do crazy stuff
you'd be really mad at an adult for
don't for doing but they're kids
and they keep see
let's get back let me check my timer and
see where was that I haven't checked it
in a while
oh my timer is up yeah that makes sense
okay let me do let me go back I'll do
five more minutes in the live chat and I
wanted I think we'll do another
25-minute session after five minutes
because I didn't even get to try out the
accordion and obviously we have not
figured out how to do this I have used
this carousel with materialised on sites
before but it's been probably six months
since the last time I worked with it so
I know it can work and I've got it
working before just not working yet so I
see there's some some suggestions in the
live chat so after this 5-minute break
I'll try out some of your suggestions
and and then give the accordion a shot
let's see let me scroll up a bit
Peter asks how to learn to code how to
find motivation how to get advanced I
really want to learn how to code but I
haven't found any motivation to learn to
code I have many reasons but I can't
find motivation let's see and Blake asks
well why do you want to learn to code
Peter says for a job experience ethical
hacking and being able to create my own
programs and analyst says don't look for
motivation because you can't look
because you can't wait forever choose to
be more disciplined Blake says so you
want to be successful Peter said yeah
okay and Pete Peters only in his teens
so
Jambi says don't try to learn everything
at once take one step at a time
Blake says you could try to Pomodoro
Technique okay yeah so my advice for
that is there could be a lot of
different reasons for lack of motivation
right I mean if you've got a lack of
motivation for a really long time
maybe maybe codings not really for you
you know but occasionally lack of
motivation could be died tied to you
know exercise diet mental health just
whatever other stuff you have going on
relationships like there's so many other
factors that have nothing to do with
coding that could be causing a lack of
motivation so I would say first off is
think about what else is going on in
your life that could possibly be causing
that I mean I'm not like a counselor or
anything like that but just from my own
experience a lot of times my lack of
motivation has nothing to do with the
code it's other things so think about
that if you can find where you think the
problem is and fix it and do something
to get rid of that problem or overcome
it then great maybe you'll have more
motivation but in the meantime I would
try setting some goals some you can have
your main goal but try to break it down
into really short manageable goals so
Blake had mentioned the Pomodoro
Technique and let me just share with you
you know if you haven't seen it already
on the stream I'm going to share with
you my Trello board my technique that I
use here so I have broken up my tasks
into small chunks into Pomodoro sessions
which is a 25-minute session I do 25
minutes that take a five minute break if
I repeat that four times the fourth
break is a ten
minute break but you can see these
little numbers here in in blue these are
how many sessions I think something's
gonna take and try to never assign eight
or more sessions to thing because then
that's that's too large of a chunk it's
hard to estimate try to keep it as small
as possible and then it's it's easier
because you if you'll see that you're
moving things over you know you're
moving things to the done list your
to-do list gets smaller and your done
list gets bigger and that's its it is
kind of motivating to be able to see
that and instead of thinking like I have
to make this huge project
you just know usually what I do what I
try to do and I don't always do this
consistently is at the beginning of the
week I look at my schedule how many
meetings are having things like that and
I think about how many Pomodoro sessions
can I reasonably do this week and I'm
just throwing out a number let's say I
decide I can only do 20 this week I look
up here and I put over here and they're
ready for dev I put in there 20 worth of
of tasks right so I want this all to add
up to 20 then for that week I know what
I have to do and I just keep moving it
over to in progress moving it over to
done if I don't get through them all
then maybe I need to you know be really
more realistic with my estimates I
adjust the next time if I flew through
them all too fast then maybe I you know
I need to adjust differently but that
way I broke I have my big project my big
picture is the whole Trello board then I
have it broken down by week then I have
it broken down by into small chunks so
you know sometimes as small as a
25-minute session or I can even go a
half sometimes I have a half a session
so that helps me sometimes especially
when I'm not motivated if I can look
over here and say all right this is
super easy this will be an easy win for
me to get some confidence and get
started at add a favicon right great
I'll move that over you know let's say
this sounds too intimidating for me all
right fine this is going over here I'm
not gonna worry about it for now let's
let's add this I know I can get this
done so I do this and it moves to done
and I think yes I have one one already
that's done it just helps out so make
something like this if you don't have a
project to work on now you can make
something like this for your studies
right so look at an online course or
something like that and break it down
you know try to break it down if it's a
really large course maybe each chapter
could have its own Trello board and then
within the chapter you might have
sections I mean however whatever
breakdown makes sense for you but the
bottom line is you break it down into
very very small manageable chunks and
then you get little wins
little and it just builds so that's my
advice
it's it works for me it's not like magic
that I'm really efficient now and
productive some days I am some days I'm
not but this really helps me to be
consistent get things done and I can
always look back and be accountable and
say man I did not do a lot of you know
tasks today or this week or whatever
like what's going on so there's other
benefits as well but for your situation
in terms of motivation you know I think
this would you potentially be beneficial
they move these back and my five minutes
timer is up so I didn't get through very
much but I want to try to implement some
of these solutions for for this just
going to spend a few minutes more on
this what's supposed to be here this
carousel and if I can't get it working
then we'll just leave it and we'll move
on and we'll throw an accordion here in
the middle and see how that looks and
depending on how much time we have after
that left in the session we may you know
just quickly
throw in another section in here we'll
see alright so here's a suggestion
height hundred percent and I excite four
hundred wheel quit okay alright good
idea so oops I'm looking here
let's try this out No let's see if I can
just do lights oops
yeah okay and I'll actually want more
than 400 there huh
okay
so so basically something like this is
what I was thinking now this is not
exactly what I want so let's see where
the dots at doubt lay down here I don't
know that this will work out as it is
now so I may have to if I really want to
carousel here I may end up having to
make find another plug in or just make
our own carousel because evidently I
need a fixed width I can't have a
percentage with that's going to be kind
of tough potentially what I could do is
just get rid of these completely and
then add in my own icons and then have
those shift the cards that's an option I
could do that I've done that before with
this carousel so if I were going to use
this what I would probably do is I mean
I fixed the styling I don't want this
centered anymore but I would probably
have some sort of icons either in the
middle maybe if the table some sort of
arrow icons so that there'd be an
indication that you could skip through
the through the carousel so also though
there's there's still the problem of
that that height so we'll see I still am
open to suggestions on how to display
that content the only restrictions we
have for that content in terms of the so
will be featured student profiles news
and events so the only restrict sorry I
left because one of my co-workers was
peeking in through the window and I
don't know if they wanted me or they
were just trying to get on YouTube so
the only restrictions are that those
three content types are visible at the
top so let me zoom out so they're
visible at least somewhat at the top
that's it and we have to be able to play
multiple pieces of that content so it
doesn't have to be like this
the only other restriction I would add
is it has to fit in somewhat with
material design style I don't care if we
go if we go a little bit you know then
in our more creative but it has to be
that so let's see
and the suggestion to set a height and a
max height was from Alexander so thank
you
okay so let's let's do an accordion here
and so we'll grab did I forget to set
forget to set my timer okay
well if we remember we'll end this at
about five minutes left on the timer so
somewhere between five and ten minutes
left so let's checkout materialize for
our accordion I think they call
collapsible yeah there we go
so you said they do the collapsible and
we gotta initialize this so let's just
copy over this initialize first and yeah
I'll probably want it like this with a
pre-selected section so we'll just need
to put active on there
okay we probably do want it like this
okay all right I want to try the pop out
I like how it looks the only problem is
I have seen some like Jang keenest when
the pop out is used on phones so I don't
know if there's been any improvement
since the last time I tried this it has
been a while so if I notice when I'm
testing like if we do use this and I
notice when testing that it's kind of
janky on some machines then I'll
probably go with this
oops
so this section we have this card here
this column is now going to be our
accordion section let's check it out
whoa so I guess I'm not importing any
icons right now so that's definitely not
gonna look like that
where's that pop out actually let me
move this on my other screen here for a
second
then I don't have to keep flipping back
and forth as much pop out and we want to
make this active see where that needs to
go
so we add the active class to the header
and then that's going to make sure that
it's open right off the bat
okay now let me see so I think it was
John Hansen that had the idea for an
accordion is this like you're thinking I
mean ignore the weirdness going on here
because I'm not importing the icon font
but is this what you were thinking or am
I am I mistaken that
so I guess I'm thinking this would end
up being the events and at this top part
would be the date and then date of event
and brief title and then more info would
be down here probably including a link
as well and I'm wondering how small this
actually would get yeah I'm not sure
that I'm not sure the three columns is
it's doable for this content and then
when we get down you know even even at
this screen with it's still kind of
tight
yeah I'm not sure
hmm
okay let's John says four columns are
much easier to work with I mean I was
kind of thinking that the these columns
are too narrow so I was thinking the
other way of you know this content maybe
needs to be two columns or at least
maybe I don't know
I guess I could do something like this I
think we actually think we'd have to do
something like this
you get to change the column classes so
that it's medium is 12 and then large it
goes to 4 so let's see it should be
about 900 but see when we do that though
these get huge like that yeah it's
I don't know it's not really a simple a
simple fix for for this section I think
all right let's make one more section I
think I just I would like to think about
with this section here but let's do one
more section and I want to try out that
let's see image on the right drop down
on left J says image on right drop down
on left and then call them 6o hmm so
basically we'd have two columns yeah
knowing is we have three pieces of
content so that third piece would just
be hanging out
yeah I I mean I can mess around with
different calls and things but let's
make let's let's do this so if we're
gonna do I added this container class
here but I'm not gonna put this next row
inside that container class so let me
make sure yeah it's so what I'm gonna do
is outside that container class I'm
gonna put in a div and I will need to
make it and make it a row and then
within that row we'll just have actually
for now for now let's just give it an H
tag it'll be more than an H tag though
for now but or eventually so let's give
it an h2 and we want this to be I'm
gonna put these in line for now
eventually they go in a CSS file
color
I'm gonna make the background color that
for now I don't know that I would
actually want that to be the real
background color but I have that hex
code memorized so we're gonna go with
that and then the banner would be white
text
let's see now I didn't give it a height
so we'll see what it there we go said it
did something here maybe it's not I
typed in white test white text and we
could we could either give this a fixed
height which actually that might not be
a bad idea
so what we can do is say let's give it a
class of
feline container and give this lets get
300 pixels or I'm sorry not a width a
height 300 pixels let's see see what
that gives us okay not bad actually this
was supposed to be see where that's not
working
maybe it's not it maybe it's just
supposed to be via line so materialise
comes built in with some vertical
alignment classes which evidently I'm
not using properly I still have the
materialized documentation feline Oh
feline rapper that's it so it's not VLAN
containers feeling rapper and then I'm
also she's that centers the text as well
I was waiting for the auto refresh again
which does not happen okay let's put the
center on here see if it works
no I just not working all right let's go
okay so when you do a margin:0 auto so
that's the top and bottom margin is 0
and then Auto means I mean basically you
split the right and left margins equally
so let's let's give that a shot no
something must be
why is it doing this
that's interesting and this should see
that soon
now what did I do I missed I messed up
the syntax did I know I didn't why is it
then not being applied oh yeah I did
mess it up there we go
supposed to be equals
there we go all right so that works so
essentially I'm thinking of where is in
the main site we had let me show you the
main site again on the main site we have
section breaks with you know these big
images which that takes a lot to load
those images I'm thinking no we don't
need those huge images but it's still
nice to break up all that white space so
we have something like this a banner I
don't know that I would make the banner
this big normally unless we had content
that warranted it being that big but
usually I like I don't know let's say
around 50 pixels of padding depending on
what's what's in here so 50 above and 50
below whatever text is in there yeah so
we would have it like this to break up
sections I think I said earlier I was
thinking that so like like maybe this
quote would be a good thing to put in a
banner to break things up and then
between each section we could
potentially have some sort of banner
that might not be a bad place to put
things like this that are in this column
so you or you know down here we have
things in this column so we'd have to
see like and you have things like this
where it's you know other calendars are
also in here I don't I don't know that I
want to have multiple calendars it might
be better that one calendar and that
calendar could be filtered instead of
having lots of calendars so
I'm not sure like this could definitely
be you know one of those sections you
know where we have you know a bunch of
videos yeah all right so that's the idea
oh that's the plan now the that's up for
it is okay well I mean this section is
probably going to be one of the toughest
sections the rest of the sections are
pretty straightforward
I need a title and I need text content
potentially I could do column select for
this section I could have the text
content taking up half this space and
then right next to it taking the other
half I could have this
we've probably change this into a card
but it could definitely do that other
sections will be a little bit more
complicated like this one also I'm gonna
remove these images in these images to
get rid of just to get rid of even more
images that don't really need to be
there but that's basically going to be
the pattern so I think what I'll
probably do is I'm still working on
infinite putting the finishing touches
on project two but then as soon as I'm
done with that I'm gonna be doing more
work on this during the day so I won't
necessarily be doing all of this you
know for the stream so some little get
done and you know off stream but you
know I'll give recaps of what was done
so I think I'm probably almost out of
time on a timer yeah because we started
this late right so this is actually
almost on the zero now so now that I've
kind of shared as as best as I could try
to explain
what my vision is for this I'm
definitely open to suggestions just keep
in mind overall I want it to be clean I
want to use as few images as possible
and I want to try to keep as much of the
content as possible although I'm like I
am open to taking some out right so we
are moving some of this we don't need to
keep these menus so if there is content
that happens to be repetitive it you
know if it's the same as other content
on the page I'm ok with maybe trying to
take that out so anyway any suggestions
you have I definitely appreciate that
except I've said this before but I have
to do design because we don't really
have a web designer but I don't really
consider my strong suit to be design so
a lot of my design is trial and error
and asking other people their opinions
you know testing things out so anyway at
this point I'm gonna go over to the live
chat and finish up I did have oh I had
one awesome announcement that I I don't
want to forget so I'm gonna say it right
now so some of you may remember that at
one point I was submitting proposals for
talks to conferences and one of them got
accepted so I've gotten a few rejections
but I did get accepted so I will be
speaking at November November 27th and
28th in Nashville Tennessee so I don't
know which day I'll be speaking or what
time yet I just accepted the the
invitation to speak and so get this my
topic that I had given in is how live
coding changed my life so I'm gonna be
talking about all of you
at the November conference so if you're
in the area or or your like if your
company pays to go to conferences or
something or you just happen to be super
rich and can fly wherever you want come
check out November and yeah hopefully
they put it on they put the talks on
YouTube that would be cool and then
everybody could see it before whenever I
said I was submitting talks I think we
had some talking a lot chat about how it
would be nerve-wracking to give a talk
in front of those people and I said oh
I'm not I don't worry about that right
well now that I actually got accepted
I'm a little nervous the thought of it
is is I don't know I've never been to
this conference so I don't know what to
expect I have no idea how big it is how
many people will be there the others
some of the other speakers that I know
will be there I've seen them speak
before they speak all over the world at
the biggest conferences so I mean now
those are the keynote speakers I'll just
be giving I don't even know what it'll
be called but you know it'll be probably
at most 45 minutes maybe a half hour I
don't know
so anyway I'm super excited about that
and I actually I applied to another con
from confidence after this and I sent in
a proposal for talk to another
conference that'll be next year in
Charleston South Carolina so anyway yeah
I was actually just starting to think
like you know what maybe talking to
conferences isn't for me nobody's been
interested in my proposals and then I
woke up this morning and there it is I
got an email I almost just deleted the
email cuz every email I get has been
we're sorry but you can come to the
conference anyway if you pay for a
ticket but luckily I didn't delete it I
scrolled down and saw congratulations
and was like this has to be a mistake
right
anyway cool
enough enough about about that let me
get to your questions I'm gonna try to
get through all the questions and I
wonder Patrick's I don't think Patrick's
here today in the live chat but Patrick
is from Tennessee so hopefully Patrick
can either come to the conference or if
he's close enough in Tennessee maybe it
would be cool to meet up or something
like that
I actually I think that would be really
cool that if I end up going to
conferences you know elsewhere or if you
all end up in the area I mean probably
the only place would be a conference
near me would be Pittsburgh but it would
be cool to try to meet up you know in
real life somewhere not in like a creepy
sort of way but like at a public place
or like a coffee shop kind of way you
know and then maybe even I mean it'd be
cool to even do like a little video or
something if we got together and then
show it on the livestream
depending on the Wi-Fi we could probably
live stream from my phone but anyway
let's let me scroll back up excited I
tell you what my wife was super excited
because immediately she was like are you
gonna take me she always wants to travel
and she actually has a lot of family in
in Tennessee right around Nashville so
that'll be cool for her she'll get to
visit with some relatives
trying to find trying to find where I
left off at
okay Sebastian says materialise has a
class for large screens in my screen I
guess it's a medium-sized that looks
pretty good with that margin okay yeah
the the smaller size margin looks okay
it just looked like it was too big for
the large screen sebastian asks why does
the free code can't tag not pop-up when
I start writing so anyway I'll show you
Sebastian
it pops up for me I don't know what was
going on but pops up also I always say
this I forgot to say it this time
because I have a decent amount of
viewers still the last part of this is
all question and answer so I'm not going
to be doing any more like coding work
for this stream so if you're not
interested in the question answer
totally understand or you know if you
gotta go that's that's cool too but I
would like it if you can stay to stick
around even if you don't have a question
because I love to have your expertise in
helping to answer these questions
because I certainly you know have
limited knowledge there's just way too
many things going on in web development
to have all the bases covered so so if
you can stick around and help out
wonderful if you have a question you
know put that in the live chat and and
we'll get through it I'll try to get
through all the questions I don't have
any meetings or anything to go to so
other than being really hungry there's
no reason for me to stop the stream
right in the house see
if Sebastian says that indentation I
know it's driving me crazy
I need to get some sort of weight shift
alt f4 auto format
okay so load Bojan says shift alt f4
auto format
whoa cool nice is it really
nested that deep I guess it is crazy all
right so so far this dream the most
useful comment goes to Bo Jan that's
amazing shift old F Auto formats in
Visual Studio code that you just you
just made my day because that
indentation was killing me
Simon Says what language for back-end if
you mean what language am i using for
this project
it's c-sharp it's dotnet asp.net if you
if it's more of a general question as to
what language I prefer for back-end it
would be node no jazz Blake asks about
how I did the carousel card effects
John said built-in the material you I
actually i'm using materialized I get
them mixed up to note I'm using both of
them materialized CSS has it built in
it's a jQuery plug-in that's that's
built in to materialize
Blake's asking if you can use material
UI with just regular HTML as far as I
know um no I don't think so I think yeah
I mean it's maybe it's possible to
change a few things and make it work but
if you're using regular HTML I I go with
materialize because it's made for that
and then if I'm the one react I go with
material UI so it's a little bit
different you know switching back and
forth in terms of what the code looks
like in classes and things you have to
remember but in terms of what users see
that's very similar
John Hanson said Jessie likes to square
peg into a round hole yeah I guess
that's accurate
okay I got to the part of the live chat
when when my son Ambrose was in there so
hi everybody saying hi and so cute so so
thanks John B says very awesome wife and
kid thank you I appreciate that yeah
that's fun my kids don't come often to
my office but it's fun when they when
they do come I think it's good for kids
to see like maybe it's nice when my kids
see me working right cuz when I'm home
well I do work from home too but a lot
of times when I'm home like I'm just
relaxing you know I don't want my kids
to grow up thinking like Oh dad's just
that guy that lays around all day not
that I laid around all day at home but I
don't want my kids thinking that that's
their concept of an adult male it's just
some guy that comes home and eats dinner
and just hangs out right I like for them
to think of me also as being like
working hard so I think it's cool for
the for my kids to see me you know at
work and at home
anyway that's that's my parenting
philosophy moment for the day
okay so Blake says I'm doing the
algorithms on free code camp and I feel
like I just look it up and I'm not
getting any help yeah some of the
algorithms can be tough I mean I guess
my thing with the algorithms is I'm
pretty stubborn with it so it takes a
long time for me to to look something up
I'm more likely to be honest with you
I'm more likely to just quit and do
something else than I am to look it up
which is probably part of the reason why
it's taking me years to get through free
code camp all the free code camp
challenges but my thing is like if if
it's taking a really really long time
sometimes it is better to try to look it
up I mean I try to look up as little as
possible so that I can try to get as
much of it as I can on my own but
sometimes you just have to and then
maybe the next ones you know sometimes
it's just you know that we just don't
see the answer and then once we see the
answer it's like oh that's obvious you
know so I guess it's just like just to
try to keep on moving and just have
momentum do your best without looking it
up but if you have to don't worry about
it you can always go back and try it
again later once you give your brain a
little while to kind of forget I found
like a lot of the stuff I did on free
code camp you know like two years ago I
don't really remember at all so when I
go back now and try to do it I look at
what I did before and I can say like oh
I would do it differently now and
sometimes I do redo the problems
differently like especially you know I
use like es2015 syntax you know what it
cleans things up a lot it's just I don't
know I think as long as you keep trying
and you're persistent you're still going
to get something out of it the key is
just to do a little bit every day even
if you don't get the problem right at
least you're thinking and you're working
you're seeing you know JavaScript syntax
like it's gonna stick in your brain
eventually it may not seem like it's
short term but longer term in a couple
months you know you should be able to
look back and say like man I'm so much
farther along than I was then you know
you'd be able to look at some of your
code like look at some of the exercise
you did on free code camp a few months
back and say wow I would you know I'd be
able to solve this so much faster now so
I don't know I mean keep at it I've
definitely had those moments where I'm
like man I'm just stuck it just feels
like I'm not getting anywhere but you
know try to do your best to work through
it
all right so I don't know how easy that
was to see on the screen but traphouse
sent a note just put a racist comment in
the live chat so I will have none of
that in my live chat so that that person
is is blocked and message is deleted so
I'm sorry that I even had the live chat
on the screen so that someone may have
seen that so I apologize to anyone who
saw that and was offended by that so
yeah so I don't I guess there's not
really an official code of conduct that
I've ever posted for the live chat but
we try to keep everything like polite
you know and nice so you know we don't I
don't there's no reason to be be mean or
vulgar or offensive in a live chat about
writing code right I don't mind if we
have heated discussions about which code
editor is the best but I don't want to
get personal about any you know anything
else so anyway so 99.9% of every comment
that's ever been in the live chat has
been entirely fine this is in fact the
first time there's ever been any sort of
racist comment on here
although somebody get into a fight in
some other language for someone else so
there could have been crazy stuff but I
just couldn't read it because it was in
some language I don't know so anyway
just just a reminder not that you all
need that like I said everybody's pretty
good so just something to keep in mind
let's see
speech direction I should be left alone
a healthy standard says only love and
only love positive people yeah that's it
that's what we want here ha ha Bryant
says Adam is obviously the best code
editor that's a non-issue I don't want
to start another debate
we've had so many code editor
discussions in here
let's see Blake says thanks for the tips
I just looked at my map and realized
that it had skipped me far ahead I was
wondering why I hadn't heard about some
of the concepts all right
maybe that was the whole problem and
maybe if you go back I have you a lot
easier for you that would definitely
make things difficult Blake's in
response to Brian's saying Adams the
best code editor Blake says you meant
Visual Studio code right Rowan says you
mean which is the best editor and why
not Emacs that would not I know you guys
are just messing around but we're at the
end of the question answer session I'm
not going to get into editors again if
you want to talk about editors go into
the slack channel for for this stream
you could you could start a whole
channel and slack a whole discussion
that could just be editors and it's fine
with me
Roman says hello from Russia hey how's
it going thanks for watching
hi John B says privyet the Roman marshal
cool alright I got to the end of the
last yet so thanks everyone for watching
thank you for all your help didn't get
quite as much done as I wanted to I
definitely got tripped up by that
carousel
working like I wanted it to I'm sure it
was probably user error on my part I
will be on today's Friday right so I'll
be back on Monday I have a great weekend
everyone
and I don't thing I have anything else
for you right now
anyway you are awesome today as always
yeah I'll be back and trying to find the
button to stop the stream here it is so
I'll be back on Monday again have a
great weekend
and see you later